In a documentary about the making of
Avatar, director James Cameron revealed
that the original design for the Na'vi
was much less graceful and feline than
the aliens we see on screen. Because Avatar
is a love and assimilation story where Jake
Sully falls for Neytiri and becomes one of
the Na'vi, the character designers opted
to make the Na'vi humanoid and exotically
beautiful. In the documentary, Cameron said,
"I wanted people to say, 'I
want to be one of them.'"
Cameron told Gizmodo that he relied on feedback
from his crew of artists for this reason,
adjusting the design until they felt it was
plausible that a human like Jake could be
attracted to one. Cameron also said that
they emphasized the alien and the animal a
bit more in the older Na'vi characters to make
meeting the future in-laws more frightening.
In an interview with Playboy, Cameron explained
how he designed Neytiri to appeal to his male
audience's id. He explained that the heterosexual
male perception of female beauty was extremely
unrealistic, and he didn't expect male viewers
to be grossed out by the Na'vi in light of this.